well democrats have a new midterm
message if anything goes bad just blame
vlad the president doubling down on his
claim that record inflation is putin's
fault
i'm sick of this stuff
[Applause]
we have to talk about it because the
american people think the reason for
inflation is government spending more
money
simply not true make no mistake
inflation is largely the fault of putin
democrats didn't cause this problem
vladimir putin
did and we're and we are working on to
fix it
working on to fix it
it doesn't look like americans are
falling for that talking point neither
is the judge as you can hear a new wall
street journal poll finding biden in the
dims are losing ground on key issues 57
percent of voters unhappy with biden's
job performance jesse if i had a line
graph but i don't because i just fill in
on this show if i had a line graph i
could show the rise in inflation over 12
months and yet we're going to be
convinced or they're going to attempt to
convince us no no no this is all over
the events of the last couple of weeks
thank you yeah it's like that
everybody knows it
what else are you going to do if i'd
blame putin too if i were joe biden it
is i mean come on when you're a
politician when things are good
you say hey that was me i did it and
when things aren't good you say what are
you looking at me for who was the other
guy so this is all he has and he's now
promised americans that things are going
to get normal now and the new normal is
more dangerous and more expensive and
the people didn't vote for that so he's
going to have to figure out a way to
tell his party to
i'm not going to say it on the air and
he just needs to run like a one-termer
you know
know you're not getting re-elected screw
the donors screw the base i'm gonna do
what's right for the american people if
he could do that and focus on
being a populist president
lower gas prices
try to help out with inflation he'd be
much better off but right now he is
going off a cliff and it's going to be a
blood bath in november off this one
issue harold let me just go through the
excuses inflation's transitory it's the
broken supply chain it's actually a good
thing i believe jinsaki tried to tell us
and now it's vladimir putin will we pull
off these excuses i don't know i'm not
sure that
any of us believe that vladimir putin is
not a big reason for some of the
challenges we're having globally uh with
prices going up and perhaps recessionary
pressures affecting other parts of the
world is it all of the was this this
problem exists before putin of course of
course it did there's no doubt we were
facing some inflation
and this problem has complicated things
i think you've laid it out about right
about what the president has to do to
get reelected uh and more more
importantly in his in his short-term
vision what democrats have to do to uh
avoid losing majorities in the house and
the senate
it's a long way away still uh and we'll
see uh but
democrats have to be brutally honest 57
disapproval rating for the president
translates into a lot of losses in
november congressional seats and senate
seats you got to get that number back 50
50 and you got to figure out what's most
on people's minds crime the border
inflation he manages us out of this
ukraine thing in a meaningful way much
like george h.w bush got a huge bounce
when he ejected saddam hussein from
kuwait this president standing up to
vladimir putin on behalf of nato and the
west it will help them as well but you
have to address the domestic issues
george w bush lost you know why because
he neglected economic issues you focus
on the economy and you're honest with
the american people what you've done
what you've done right what you've done
wrong and what you're going to do to
correct it
we can salvage some of these seats and
the president can find himself in a
better spot two years from now hey judge
if you dig into this wall street journal
poll the one place that president biden
does seem to have a little bit of
positivity is on ukraine is on these
international conflicts does this
promise to actually be a life preserver
for the bite administration not a chance
because in the end
everything is about how much you can
afford how it affects your life whether
or not you can pay for groceries and buy
gas or pay for medicine or do all the
things that everyday americans do
spending now 300 more a month for every
household look the truth is that the
democrats in order to win have to stop
lying
it is that simple
stop lying
stop telling me this is putin's fault
stop telling me inflation is transitory
stop telling me that this administration
is in favor of you know fossil fuels
when we could do all the sods or the
sound on tape of biden saying yeah we're
gonna put an end to it look all
americans want is honesty all we want is
honesty and the fact that you know biden
is saying at least putin's wrong i mean
we're shocked that's like a reasonable
position to say
uh but but in the end it's not going to
help him it's not going to help him his
vice president's not going to help him
his policies are not going to help him
well to both of their points dagan this
ukrainian russian conflict will go on
for some time inflation might be there
when it's all said and done i was in
ohio yesterday doing a diner for fox and
friends i had diners projecting oh i
think gas will go to ten dollars a
gallon
what is what will he be dealing with in
terms of inflation and gas gas prices by
the time we get to the midterms
uh there's no way to know it certainly
could remain elevated because you have
this biden in his posse of fools who
will not do everything in their power to
produce fossil fuels and tap one of our
greatest resources here which again is
prosperity for us it's protection for
nations that currently rely on russia
for natural gas and oil and it starves
vladimir putin and this war on ukraine
but they won't do it number one biden
and incorporate his problem
since his beginning of his time in
office is that he believes that the
electorate and voters are stupid and
he's talked to them
like that all along we're just a bunch
of hay seeds and hicks and rubes and
deplorables and rednecks and if you just
particularly if you disagree with them
and question them on their recklessness
like their attack on fossil fuels from
day one then they really dismiss you and
that is their biggest problem i can tell
you that if somebody walked up to my
father at the food lion and said to him
uh you pay how much were your groceries
peyton's problem or how much did you pay
for gas putin's problem my father would
glare at them and say did somebody hit
you in the head
and then you would walk out into the
parking lot and he would saw the side
view mirrors off that tesla with the
hatchet in the back of his pickup truck
and that's how all americans feel right
now especially when they got sold
the the lie about buildback better is
going to lower inflation we need to
spend more money to bring inflation down
you know who killed bill back better
putin yeah
i want to see that video of your dad
hatcheting off those side view mirrors
yeah i like that
hey sean hannity here hey click here to
subscribe to fox news youtube page and
catch our hottest interviews and most
compelling analysis you will not get it
anywhere else